-Reese.
-Yes.
-You know we love you.
Welcome back to the show.
Thanks for being here. I want
to talk about "Busy Betty."
-Oh, yes!
-I also want to talk about --
You're in New York.
You're doing "The Morning Show"
here in New York.
-Yeah, we're shooting
"The Morning Show" in New York.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I love -- I love that show.
I think we talked about it
last time you were on here.
But we had Jon Hamm on recently,
and he said that
he's joining the cast.
-The Hamm. Yes!
-Jon Hamm is joining the cast?
-I know.
And we are beyond excited.
-He's the greatest.
-Can you -- What can you say --
Or you can't say
what his character is?
-Not allowed to say.
-You can't.
Do you have scenes with him?
-Did he say?
-He said that he's having a lot
of fun with Billy Crudup,
which --
-Okay.
Well, then I can't say anything.
But -- No, he's the greatest.
-I know. We said that already.
But is he in a scene
with Jennifer Aniston?
-Uh...
-We don't even know.
We can't say anything.
When is it coming out?
-Um...
-You can't say that either?
-I can't say that.
[ Laughter ]
All I know is he's amazing.
He's great.
I think it's been everywhere.
He has a whole -- some scenes
with Jennifer Aniston.
-Ohh. That's a little hot goss
right there.
-That's a little tea.
-I have --
We have something in common.
-We do?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
We both love Dolly Parton.
-Well, come on. I can't.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have that in common
with a lot of people.
-I mean --
-I was just with Dolly --
You're going to be jealous.
-What?
-I shot a --
-Her Christmas special?
-Yes.
-Didn't get the call.
-Yeah.
-Did not get the call.
-"Mountain Magic Christmas."
I'm in a full-on scene singing
and dancing with Dolly Parton.
-Stop right now.
-Yeah, it's the greatest.
I went to Tennessee.
-What?!
-I went to Tennessee --
-And you didn't call me?
-I didn't ca-- I'm sorry. Yeah.
But you know what I did?
I went to Sevierville,
which is her hometown.
-Yeah.
-And I went to -- I said
I got to find a local
mom-and-pop barbecue place.
So I went and found a place
called Preacher's barbecue.
And I don't know if they watch
the show, but they were awesome.
-They will now.
-And one guy was there.
I went.
It was delicious barbecue.
And I said,
"Do you have T-shirts?
I go, "Do you have T-shirts?
Cause I'd love to get
just a shirt from you."
He said, "I could check
in the back, see what we have.
I don't even know
what we have here.
if we have a T-shirt.
People don't buy T-shirts."
I go, "I don't know."
He goes, "Well, we have one."
He goes, "It's just a logo."
And I go, "Yeah.
And what's on the back?"
And on the back it said,
"We're kind of a pig deal."
[ Laughter ]
That's the best thing.
That's the best thing I could
ever purchase in my entire life.
Now, I know you --
-I need one of those T-shirts.
-Right?
Isn't that a great T-shirt?
-Yeah.
-I know you've met Dolly
and talked with Dolly before.
-I'm making a movie with Dolly.
Well, I'm -- Okay.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
-Not a Christmas holiday film.
-Well, I mean, sorry.
Some of us didn't get invited
on her Christmas special.
But, no, she wrote this book
with James Patterson
called "Run, Rose, Run."
-That's right.
-And my company is producing it.
-You are the greatest.
Come on. Are you kidding me?
You get to work with Dolly?
-Yes!
-How awesome is that?
-I don't know if she'll let me
be in the movie, but I get to
stand on the side and go,
"That was amazing."
-Can we talk about your
production company, by the way?
Hello Sunshine.
-Aww. Thanks.
-Congratulations on --
Everything you're doing...
-Thank you.
-...turns to gold.
-It's quality stuff.
It's great stuff.
You just got named by
"Hollywood Reporter" one of
the TV producers of the year.
-That's so amazing.
-That's a giant deal.
-Yeah.
-Does that mean
more work for you?
'Cause once you reach that list,
everyone's like,
"Let's just call Hello Sunshine,
see if she'll produce
something we're doing."
-Yes, yes, it does, Jimmy.
More work is good.
I'm so lucky.
-Isn't it fun to see it grow
and become --
-It's incredible.
And then we get to work
with amazing people.
We have a show with Zoe Saldana
coming out this month.
And then next year we have
a show with Jennifer Garner,
which is really exciting.
-[ Gasps ] Wow!
-It's just so much cool stuff.
-Yeah, and the book club
is crushing.
-Yeah, the book club's
doing really well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're just -- Everything.
I've got to say --
-Doing really well.
-It's because you're a hard
worker and you're just awesome.
This is something I saw
that you responded to on Twitter
and it made me laugh.
It says, "If Reese Witherspoon
and Dwayne the Rock Johnson
were ever fighting in an arena
and only one
could come out alive...
I'd bet my life savings on
Reese Witherspoon winning.
Don't ask me why."
-Wait. Can I tell you a story?
I actually sent that
to the Rock,
and he's like,
"She's not wrong."
-Wow! Dwayne said it.
-Dwayne's like --
He's like, "Not wrong."
-Not wrong.
I put my money on Reese
Witherspoon all the time.
-I get a little scrappy, guys.
Don't count out the shorty.
The shorty will come for you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can we talk about "Busy Betty"?
-Yes. Please.
-I love this. My girls
are going to love this.
-Yay!
-I love the illustrations,
by the way.
-Yes. It's all about m--
I actually, during the pandemic,
I had this idea about a little
girl who builds businesses.
But I was like, "Wait.
I built a bunch of businesses
when I was little."
So it's all about
how I had a lot of energy.
I was kind of the kid who --
their parents got called to say,
"Reesy's talking a little bit
too much in class today,
and we're going to have to
separate her from her friends."
But I just had so much energy
and so many ideas.
And when my brother
would pitch businesses to me,
I would be like,
"I could do that."
And so I started
lemonade stands, magic shows.
And then I started
selling barrettes
out of my desk
in the third grade.
That one got shut down.
[ Laughter ]
-Of course. Famous story.
-Wasn't up to code.
Had supply-chain issues.
[ Laughter ]
-Supply-chain issues.
-I realized
ever since I was little,
I just loved
building businesses.
-Yeah, and that's good.
I think that's great for anyone
who reads this and goes --
'Cause when you have a mind
of a child, which...
-Yeah.
-...some of us do.
-That's what we have in common.
-Yeah. Being creative and just
going, "I've got an idea."
And you're like, "Oh, yeah.
I want to wash the dog."
And then it's a disaster,
but it turns out to be
a great business.
-Yeah, and the good thing
is people like you and me
meet responsible people
who actually keep us on track.
Which are the amazing people
you guys don't see.
They're all standing
behind stage,
but they keep the wheels
on the wagon.
-Yeah, I wouldn't be here
without everybody.
-Yeah, they're amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your team is amazing.
-Absolutely.
-Amazing, amazing.
-But I love this because I --
"Busy Betty."
I know who Betty is based on.
The name, Betty. It's your mom.
-It's my mom, yeah.
-I love your mom.
She's so cute.
-I love my mom.
And in my dedication, I say,
"Thank you for encouraging
my magical thinking."
Because you got to have somebody
who believes in your kookiness,
and my mother did.
-Yeah.
-She just was like --
She just thought it was great
and funny and charming.
-Yeah. It is good.
And it's a fun book.
A funny book. But then
look at the back of the book.
"Busy Betty" is holding a photo.
Look at this cute.
-That's me.
-That is --
That's the original Busy Betty.
-That's me.
-Wow. Glasses and all.
-Yeah.
-You're already, like,
entertaining.
-Glasses.
-"Hi!"
-My brother's hand-me-downs.
The tube socks with the sandals.
-I love the tube socks.
It's so fantastic.
-The tube socks!
-It is so cute. Come on.
Congrats on this book and thanks
again for coming on the show
and always playing with us.
We love you.
Reese Witherspoon, everybody.
"Busy Betty" is available now.
Kevin Nealon joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!